this is the welcome to the D show peace
be unto you how are you doing I'm doing
good thank God and we're here again for
another exciting episode don't go
nowhere we're going to be talking about
the purpose of why you've been created
why it's important to put down the GQ
magazine and the faculty magazines and
pick up this book to read what's the
book stay tuned to find out we'll be
right back here on the Dean show this is
the thing the danger this is the thing
this is the thing you know this is the
thesis Athene jus mean you know this is
the things that angel
this is the we're back here on the D
show with with Sam Sharif yes how are
you my brother very good how are you
today um did it all praises to the one
who created us and we are and I'm sure
the audience is very excited me toooo to
have you on the show your family members
been here you're part of a big family
over 1.5 what between 5 billion and 1.5
7 billion no manali conned your
brother-in-law sir family he's been here
you're here and we're together and we're
ready to go all right all right so you
know the time just flies by so we're
going to get right in it sure this topic
for a lot of people is taboo you know
what because they got money on their
mind they got women on their mind the
women got the men on their mind and
dunya this material world is hypnotizing
people we talk about purpose we talk
about the fulfillment of what your
purpose is why you're in this life
because we're all going to die and we're
going to be accountable and what we did
it is life so we brought you on the show
to help us cover this very important
topic and everything we cross-check with
the verbatim word of God and that's the
miracle of Islam the Quran exactly so
can you talk to us a little bit about
why it's so important that a human being
should take a timeout you don't have to
be a monk in a room sit and pray all day
right but you know be the best at
whatever career you practice why is it
important that you should take a time
and reflect about what the purpose of
life is have you ever wondered why is it
so important before we dwell in two
before we dwell on deeper topics yes I
if we look away from religion itself
just the fact that a human being needs
to remove himself from stresses of the
day that's called meditation tai chi
yoga and a Muslim or even even people
who go to a specific mass or or go to
the synagogue it's a time to pull
yourself away why is that important
because we as human beings need to find
a higher source unlike you mentioned
it's either money material world it's
something that draws us in but in
several places throughout the Quran and
if we look
Old Testament and the New Testament to
God keeps referring to a prayer and we
find when he's speaking to Moses in the
Quran may God's peace and blessings be
upon him Moses is asked to remove his
shoes and God says to him and for the
first time in we no earthly miss la lata
Lee decree established the prayer which
is a moment those five moments to
reconnect yourself with God and one of
the most important things we talked
about it last night it's not just that
spiritual connection but the physical
connection every prayer has a
prostration every prayer has a gesture
that shows I no matter how great I am
there's something greater than me and
even just as a human being there's a
greater purpose of mankind so those five
minutes help you help you put your
iPhone away for a little while help you
disconnect from facebook for five
minutes and helps you reconnect with the
earth so I think the prayer is not just
a spiritual thing but it's a connection
that makes us human beings realize we
have to help each other and through that
we can reflect we're sharing this
message of purpose based on truth yes
sir giving the people proof because we
love our brothers in humanity right so
sharing is caring yes sir so we're here
to share and the reality of depth should
wake some people up we can agree to
disagree but we know that every soul
every cell every person will taste death
so why is it important do you feel and
then again will dwell in this is kind of
an introduction just for the person
that's maybe a little bit skeptical and
they're just like come on man let's move
let's move you know I got the football
game you know I got to watch that you
know the runway models and she's gonna
watch the fashion show why is it so
important they've been flickering
through and they found they caught the
Dean show and they're like let me just
give it a chance a shot they've been on
xanax they've been depressed and you
know what they need some nourishment for
the Soul and they're sick of all the
preachers saying give us your money and
send us 599 we'll send you this fairy
does we don't need your money we just
want your time and your attentiveness so
before the reality of death comes and
people are sleeping because everything
is on their mind accept this reality but
then def comes and they wake up and it's
too late
talk to us about this this is reality
def the reality of death is inevitable
we all know from the medical standpoint
we've all experienced it but I think God
gives us a chance an opportunity in the
Quran in the second surah where God
wants us to reflect and says death is
inevitable but then he reminds us with a
very loving question kaifa tuck fulu
Nabila how could you disbelieve in a
creator how can you disbelieve in deaths
and the inevitability of weekend meeting
him k photographer luna billahi what
condom I'm rotten Viacom how can you
disbelieve in a creator how is it
possible not uh not to give it a little
bit of attention if he has created you
and then he put you to sleep then he
gave you life so our souls were created
and we know that there's a voice inside
you right now saying I think I know what
he's talking about i think it makes
sense but then God put those souls to
sleep and after 120 days of your mom
knowing she was pregnant God blew that
spirit into the angel brought it to your
mom and that was your life so how can
you not reflect on death how can you not
reflect that we are going to end no
matter if our life is made of gold it's
going to end at some point so that's our
reflection on the necessity of death the
necessity for human beings to realize
there is an end to everything and I
think that's where we're going to pick
up today and one more thing before we
cut into some people just say well he
died in peace you know what I mean he
might have been the most wretched person
we know God is the most loving and if
you turn to him with all these just
atrocious sins would a sound Hart you
turned him and you seek His forgiveness
alone he'll forgive but now you just
turned away from his signs you know what
you deny you did every corrupt moral
thing and you broke the moral code of
God and now they're like he died in
peace do people just leave this earned
dime piece and you just enter paradise
and you know or is there consequences
day of judgment you no talk just just
briefly you know the reward and this
reality of paradise right that glad
tiding of bliss and seeing your Lord and
everything you want and beyond your
magic than the Hellfire right we can't
avoid that we can't avoid punishment but
I think again if you
watching this as a TV show and it's just
something you're flipping through hell
in happiness is is abstract Helen having
is far away so let's think about it here
on earth if someone does something
wretched and they're cheating people
they're hurting people they have I could
say illegal illegal work they're selling
drugs or they're just hurting people in
this society when they die and we say
they died in peace we're peaceful
because that wretched person is dead but
that person has to then go and he's
accountable just like if i by accidently
drank poison here on earth no one would
say he did it by accident he's dead they
would say well the laws of nature that's
it he died so when we break moral law
when we break that moral code whatever
ethical system you use but we know that
code is written by our God ah God the
Creator when you break that there is
consequence so if you take two things
reflection and you take the
inevitability of death then you can say
God has asked us throughout the Quran
and even in the Bible he talks about
paradise so much but he describes it and
I think that one of the best things we
can do is look at the signs around us
look at beautiful scenery look at the
beautiful things of this world and know
that if you are allowed to have this
here imagine what's waiting for you with
a little bit of constraint and a little
bit of control what's waiting for you in
the hereafter a little bit of
self-discipline right there you
discipline yourself to be in school to
be a doctor and you'll not go to the
parties your relax your study study
study a little bit discipline here to be
of good moral conduct living by a good
moral code so you can be the best of
mankind for thank God obeying God for
the society society right just becoming
a doctor sometimes one person might like
might not say that's that's a small goal
but when you're a moral person what that
does is it benefits the society and
that's one thing we I want in today's
show I'm praying that someone leaves
saying this is not about the self this
is about the community and how can I and
what I do benefit the community that's
what we're talking about we're talking
about purpose to be the best human being
that you can be and we're going to give
you the formula here on the Dean show
God willing
we'll be right back with more and if
we're going to worship something I
figured I might as well worship the
Creator instead of any other creations
now in upon investigating the villages I
remember finding out the meaning of what
Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender yourself to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will Daisy Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God your Creator back
here on the Dean show with our special
guests we're talking about purpose we
have one shot to get it right is the
test of life we want to do good be good
and it's not according to our desires
it's according to the one who created
everything in his universe and that's
the one creator that Jesus submitted to
that Jesus call the people submit to
Moses call the people to submit to
Abraham Noah all the messengers that was
sent they came with the same message
don't worship yourself your desires a
nationality power money fame a man a
woman but worship the one who created
man and woman the one creator that's
simple it's something that is not
complicated no and we are wanting proof
now the people want proof so how can
they know you mentioned car on we know
that's the literal verbatim word of God
right right so how can people we want to
give them a taste they read every other
book and if someone says your mother
left you a note you know and you never
met her you'd want to read that note if
it was in another language you would
learn that language you would learn the
language come on but this is the only
book compiled over 23 years we have it
as an original right yeah memorize them
you memorized his entire book every time
I'm thankful to say that yes verbatim
covered a cover they are over I say
150,000 people just you know just I
would say in the world who have
memorized the book cover-to-cover
numbers could be more but yes it is
memorized it is uh it is absorbed and
recited on to generation I heard
millions have memorized it today living
today yes millions have memorized it
just there would be about a hundred
fifty thousand teachers or tools cool
schools that are teaching the
memorization and the implementation
of this book but the question becomes
why memorize it what's that what's the
importance right isn't that one one of
the miracles there are many a Miracle's
it's a book that has so many signs not a
book of science but a book of signs
there are signs in there right that is
called a person to reflect so let us
talk and give the people some of these
evidences prove let's talk about the
verbatim word of God and maybe you can
also let the people hear it in its
original because we can translate it
that's not the Quran right a crown is an
original Arabic language so how can
someone be sure they're going to put
down the fashion magazine GQ to read
this book are they wasting their time um
I don't think they're wasting their time
but let's try to outline this in fourth
gotcha this is the Dean show so it's not
like this abstract you can go back and
watch the harvard divinity school
episode you can go and he tackles a
great aspect of the Bible and Quran so
I'm not going to touch that brother
nouman ali khan came in and did the
historical facts if you remember he did
historical facts what we're gonna do
today is just simply logic the quran the
verbatim word of god revealed through an
angel to the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him speaks about a very specific
event and that's 10,000 years of
prophethood again we might be watching
and saying oh this is the Quran
Mohammed's book peace God's peace and
blessings be upon him but in the Quran
it says is that not only did this book
come to Noah but and it goes in order
there's a key a small element it goes
from Noah and then we start speaking
about Abraham Moses Jesus until the
Prophet peace be upon him and we tackle
David that would sulaiman why you
prophets that might not be mentioned in
all books but are a compilation of every
mention now the next step is if this one
book if this one book has the mention of
so many prophets what is it that that
one these prophets are bringing as a
message and that's the oneness of God
oneness of God oneness of God so now
let's pull it together and give logical
proofs first God refers to us to say if
you can't find me the unseen look at the
scene and he says no Quran that leak I
mean I aren't in love
these are the signs of the signs of your
God or your Creator now when I say God
that has to carry a lot of weight you
have to be able to say I understand that
it is one creator whether you called him
god allah aur you just acknowledged him
in your heart there still is only one
God so if we took it the step further
what is it about the Quran that makes it
unique is it only the historical the
scientific proofs is it the fact that
it's never changed its memorized no I
think the fact is going to be that if
you put down GQ and picked up the Quran
now opened it to the first chapter or to
the middle chapter and you read it and
said i would like to experience this i
would like to have an experience with
this ayah with this verse I that's our
challenge our challenge is to help
people to open the Quran and reflect on
one verse and this is my little miracle
right to my little feeling of what the
Quran did for me open the Quran read one
verse even in its translation and then
reflect on these words I fell I I
thought the whole it's a question asala
is it's a question asking why don't you
ponder on the Quran we ponder on
molecular science we ponder on whether
the qbs whether the receivers foot was
in bounce or out of Bounce we reflect on
all these tiny little things but God is
saying reflect on this book 632 pages
that people are claiming your it says to
kill and find Jews yeah let's open the
book let's read the book together if
you're going to quote one verse you're
not looking at a manuscript you're
looking on how to how you can prove that
you're right miracle of quran look at
all of the angles of scientific proof
and all the angles of historical proof
but then do one thing to yourself don't
let CNN interpret Quran for you let
someone who studied it for 10 years or
various people who have been on the Dean
show let them make that interpretation
or at least hear their opinion as well
so the Quran has these gifts reflect on
it read it and have the opportunity to
experience it both in the Arabic
language and in the English language now
speaking of CNN you are actually on CNN
we're
now for the people that are out there
like Oh what are these people man
they're from you know another planet yes
and they're coming to try to kill us you
you you address this myth yes miss
notion is fallacy talking about hey
Muslim Muslim simply one who's chosen to
submit to the one who created right just
like Moses Jesus abran they submitted to
god they were Muslim and address what
you talked about briefly on CNN saying
where your physician we should what
changed the game 19 people change the
game how did that happen because we've
been your doctor we've been your x-ray
tech whooping your accountant we've been
serving you slushies for a long time
okay talk two clips on seeing two
questions that were posed on CNN we some
Sharif yasir Qadhi and other prominent
American clerics say American Muslims
are under siege both by Islamic
extremists and some US conservative
first thing was what about jihad what do
you have to be above the Quran does say
jihad and then after jihad it says you
know find them and kill them the first
thing we propose that everyone do is we
accept this is a book of God so when God
gives you a set of rules you have to
realize it's going to cover everything
so the question that I posed and I hope
everyone can think about is would you
rather get into a street fight with no
rules where someone can bite you and
stick out a knife or would you rather
get into a ring with rules a referee and
padding and of course the the reporter
said I would like rules and I said man
is going to fight jihad is just a set of
rules so we don't fight too much and if
you flip that on its head and you say
well jihad God says to kill no no God is
telling us when you fight because you
are human beings you're gonna fight
don't cut down trees don't kill women
don't hurt those who are not fighting
you don't pillage there are so many
rules but how casual is it for me to sit
here and be like yeah I didn't let's go
kill everyone I mean Quran is not meant
to be picked and choose from one last
point to kind of pull it all together a
second thing that I wanted to mention
but never made it on air a friend of
mine came to me said why do all these
prophets want to kill people I said
let's flip the question back for a
second I said ten thousand years of
prophethood from Noah or we could say
from Noah all the way down to Prophet
peace be upon him
all of them had one message and then
when Muhammad the last prophet peace be
upon him passed away thousands of
opinions came hundreds of opinions came
would you gamble that 10,000 years of
prophethood was correct or a whole bunch
of man-made laws you make the gamble you
figure it out on your own if you don't
want to go if you want to go gut emotion
10,000 years of prophethood or a whole
bunch of people who in fighting killing
themselves for a long time quran has a
message we encourage and i encourage
everyone around is to learn to touch it
to feel it to open it and not be scared
of the actual text not be scared that
this is something foreign it's right
before you we cut to break we said if it
was in another language we would have
learned it I would definitely recommend
that everyone take the opportunity to at
least say the words because if we say
Jesus I would encourage them to say
these words in Arabic and just smile and
say Lisa so to say Jesus you have to
smile and he was smiling all the time
and to say Mohammed you have to pucker
your lips so say Mohammed and your ISA
and some of these words might sound
might not seem so foreign to you before
we go to break give them a taste of some
of the medicine they might understand
and will give them the English but what
comes to your mind any description of
the Creator describing himself that
according to man's opinion but in the
verbatim word of God anything that comes
to mind that the medicine they can hear
it got it two verses stick out very
important it it comes in the verse
number 26 subs or Aneesa where God talks
about himself and he says you read la
julio by in a legume God wants for us to
be forgiven to have clarity and to be
guided like the nations of the past but
people who try to pick and choose from
God they break his laws and they make
him an angry god they make him look like
an angry god so he says unto us you read
la Julio Bennelong kumoi dear come soon
on 11 a meal poverty come that God wants
three things for you but if you have to
pick one and that's the next verse it
says hola who you d
any at all a comb and it's not just a
nice sound but God says of these three
things guidance forgiveness and clarity
I just want to forgive I just God wants
to forgive so if you're watching the
episode you have some discomfort in your
life I really genuinely mean this ask
yourself turn to this episode and say
maybe these guys know what they're
talking about maybe they don't but he
does right no matter what you believe in
karma but there is someone who does
there's a Creator who knows turn to him
and say I want this pain in my life to
go away this depression this anxiety the
fear that I'm fat I don't like looking
in the mist stop for a second be like
look God I don't know what's being said
but I would like I would like clarity in
my life I would like forgiveness in my
life that's how God describes himself
we're gonna take a break and we right
back with more God here on a Dean show
whatever Allah commands you can do you
need to do this land has tolerance and
mercy and compassion to know that Allah
you know will forgive you as long as you
do what you need to do as long as you
turn back to him it's learn the system
of mercy and compassion and it is for
the best benefit of all of the people
that surround it Muslim and non-muslim
back here on the Dean shell and we're
discussing things that are very very
important and the Quran which is a
living miracle yes and you describe some
of these points and anyone takes a
sincere humble approach and reads this
book they will come to the conclusion
that this is not man-made snap by
Muhammad it's from the crater that
happens in earth and has all the facts
not fiction to give the person to let
their heart rest assured that this is
from the crater talks about the purpose
of life is yes talks about the purpose
of life talks about the necessity of a
man to venerate something he needs to
venerate something higher first his
parents that he can see then family it's
there and there's one eye on the Quran
that does tackle this that talks about
it is impossible wah McCann had a Laran
and you thought no one could have
produced this book other than the
creator of the heavens and earth and he
sent it down so yes we have this message
and we're praying that people will take
a sincere look at the book and not pick
and choose because at the end of the day
a text it's raining outside you're going
to go outside and check if it's raining
a text that is quoting things embryology
it is quoting the name of ha Mon I think
brother nouman tackled that there are so
many various points that are being
tackled if it's raining just go check if
it's raining if this is the book of God
please open it read it and do yourself
one favor before you get into the depths
of giving your opinion read the first
page the opening and read the first
words that open the largest section of
Quran Valley kalki tab Lori Buffy this
is a book that has no doubt no book
starts like that and it's a claim but
God can make that claim so let's
hopefully encourage our viewers to do as
we do open up we're on or even better
just type in a word in to youtube or on
the miracle see what's there there's
going to be negative but there's gonna
be a lot more positive tell us not were
a few more questions are almost out of
time I want to get these points in you
mentioned one God and our good deeds are
based of the principle of pure
monotheism yes sir not setting up any
equal with God the Creator is the crater
and we
his creatures were his creation so when
we say one God now some might worship
one guy and we never want to offend
anybody we love our brothers and sisters
and humanity we want them to reflect and
think so when we say one God in the
Quran God Almighty over and over he's
talking about his one is that just
worship Him come to him alone not to set
up a partner with him so some people
they'll take this mighty man as a god
and they'll put a Holy Ghost next to him
is this qualify as one it qualifying as
one again my opinion doesn't matter Yeah
right and I grew up studying these
concepts and I respect them the concept
of one God is that there is a sole
creator and we find this in the most
powerful section of quran which is hood
wallahu ahead Allahu slummin God is
absolute the necessity for God to have a
family is let's talk about that for a
second if God had a son if God had a son
wouldn't he tell us yes he would tell us
and through the Quran he said the
specific words voila de there's no child
there's no there's no son but what we
need to realize is if we want to look at
God through this metaphor let's even
keep the metaphor of God the Father
let's take read the Quran read the
scripture that God the Father or God our
Creator wants us to be as his children
wants us to be as the family of God so
then God would not need all of these
partners would not need manifestations
what we need to do is come back to the
fact that there is one God and he sent
us the best of mankind as his prophets
and if we change that line in the sand
between prophethood and divinity it's
it's a blur because divine profits are
just the same so Allahu Slama God is
absolute saying that there are three
breaks and God actually says no Quran
voila the hulu selasa don't say three
God is one there are manifestations of
his mercy manifestations when you look
at your child you might you might feel
an inclination this is a miracle this is
beautiful it's a miracle that God didn't
need for himself it's something he gave
to mankind the feeling or the
inclination for
production and the feeling of love God
created us in the image of love so we
are the last question we are signaling
almost out of time easter is coming
around so now what is the islamic stands
as far as we know that every human being
is accountable for their actions right
so now there's God because people are
celebrating that Jesus died for your
sins and he God died and then came back
and etc what would we have to say about
this all we have to do is to all of our
viewers we encourage them to look up
what Easter is that's all we encourage
to do for if one passed away on the
cross we would understand this from a
historical point of view but we don't
it's the the proof is not in the pudding
we encourage everyone to understand what
Easter is and whether Jesus was
crucified and what happened on that day
but from a Muslim perspective the
Islamic stance is Jesus was not
crucified but his resurrection will come
and he will return to the people i
encourage in these days not to tell you
the worship ease celebrate easter or not
i encourage you to look up what Easter
is and know what it is that we celebrate
so Islam is saying submit only to the
Creator your last 30 seconds and you're
accountable for your actions yes
nobody's paying your bill you got to pay
your bill the what you did against got
turned to God and repent only to him and
no second old original sin no confession
when Adam ate from the tree God forgave
him immediately there was no original
sin I'd like us to maybe put some more
time into that net okay so if people
want to learn Quran if they want to look
more into around you have a website sure
it's a simple website is l to r q that's
learn to read Quran L to R cube com it's
a site that will help you with letters
I'll help you with pronunciation and if
you are amongst those who can read and
recite well it'll help you better your
recitation may God Almighty the credit
rewards you and we look forward to
having you back again on these shows
very thank you very much so I conwell
alaikum Salam peace be with you and
thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the D so where'd you go Eddie
I'm here have you considered the purpose
of life look out for the bumper stickers
that we have
I'd like to thank dr. Mohammed who had
the idea for this and if you're not
thankful to the people people you're not
thing for the guy to the crater that's
what we're calling you to do deep down
in yourself as the guest said look look
just ask the creator to guide you who
facilitate away he'll facilitate a way
he's the most loving and we need to take
a timeout from the rat race of life and
reflect on what the purpose of life is
and if you'd like to pick up the
verbatim word of God call us even if
you'd like to accept the way of life all
the messengers of God believing an only
one create or not setting a partner next
to him it's only God where his creature
is his creation you only do the direct
dial up no secretary no one in between
just you and the Creator give us a call
operators are on the line to answer your
questions 1 866 to Islam we'll see you
next time here on the Dean show peace be
with you
you know this is the thing is 14 jul